I posted a pretty lengthy breakdown
about this last week but now we have an
update about the DND situation from
Wizards of the Coast this is a post on
dndbon.com entitled ogl 1.0 a and
Creative Commons they said when you give
us play test feedback we take it
seriously already more than 15 000 of
you have filled out the survey here's
what you said 88 do not want to publish
TT RPG content under the ogl 1.2 90
would have to change some aspect of
their business to accommodate ogl 1.2 89
are dissatisfied with deauthorizing ogl
1.0 a 86 are dissatisfied with the
dropped vtt policy and 62 are satisfied
with including Systems reference
document SRD content in Creative Commons
and the majority of those who were
dissatisfied asked for more SRD content
in Creative Commons basically everybody
hated this decision so the update from
Wizards of the Coast on DND Beyond here
is we are leaving ogl 1.0 a in place as
is untouched point two is we're also
making the entire SRD 5.1 available
under a Creative Commons license and
three is you choose which you prefer to
use